une très belle cause mais les en forêt
sont ils en danger on vous a posé la
question chez vous traiterez kurde avoir
votre réponse est donc la semaine
dernière vous étiez en vacances mais
votre magazine vous êtes cad rédacteur
en chef faut être solidaire voilà
déclaré dans le magazine on pouvait lire
que c'est la guerre entre obispo et ue
non seulement ils sont en pleine
écriture du spectacle qui sera le 27 et
29 novembre
ça se passe à bordeaux donc voilà est-ce
que c'est vrai cette guerre ou pas ce
n'est pas la première année qui avait
déjà fait de la détention provisoire et
youn sur les [ __ ] parce que hyundai
qui est plus de sketches plus de
d'humour et obispo plus de chansons plus
de mardyck et c'est donc déjà le sujet
des trucs très bien après évidemment que
là les levées de même si mes hobbies
paul young disent non non on s'entend
bien là une thérapie qui réfèrent de
famille aussi en toile à cestas et q
quand même il faut savoir que quand même
comme isabelle funaro acquitté parce que
le dispose pour se mettre avec michaël
youn et c'est quand même assez facile à
digérer peuvent lire on s'adore fait
super en vrai c'est quand même toujours
une blessure d'ego qui est pas si facile
à accepter et qui laissent des traces
même si depuis travaillé ensemble et c
est sur les [ __ ] ce que le sujet à
travers expliqué toute façon c'est ça
c'est qu'il n'y a pas de leader parce
que personne n'a imposé depuis goldman
était parti en 2016 est parti en 2016
que vers lecco du cicc été du goût qui
mené sa carrière est morte aussi donc du
coup y'a plus personne qui s'imposent dû
naturellement
et du coup c'est un peu là le bazar et
d'où le fait que tout le monde s'en va
et que des jeunes jean julien doré ni
loué ni stromae ni villa ni slimane tous
les jeunes ils vont pas et c'est les
anciens qui les gens adorent et palma de
robin tous à machin ils vont plus du
trou on va là tout le monde ou alors on
vous réclame un problème je vous posais
la question aussi un pourquoi est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui on peut critiquer
clairement les [ __ ] avant c'était
pas le cas bernard lavilliers effet une
fois ya cinq ans tout le monde lui est
tombé dessus
aujourd'hui vianney tout le monde le
fait et pourquoi est ce qu'aujourd'hui
on peut ne pas y aller sans être
critiqué
mais avant pour répondre à ce que vous
aider sur obispo et yoon bayou lui il a
répondu c'était sur rtl est ce qu'ils
n'en fait pas trop mais pour lui c'est
au contraire et dit même c'est mon frère
vivait à
[Rires]
pourtant je rêve pas j'ai ma petite
vidéo obispo yuna sais pas en tout cas
voilà donc et voilà pour eux je suis
vous disiez donc justement est ce
qu'aujourd'hui quel est le problème est
ce que vraiment dans les coulisses il ya
un souci pourquoi est ce que les jeunes
n'y vont plus myriam léger animons plus
signer les familles les jeunes de stars
françaises n'y vont plus mais moi je ne
pense pas sincèrement que le groupe soit
en soit en danger
les choses vont se mettre en place petit
à petit façon des rivalités il y en a
toujours eu c'est pas les premières
c'est vrai qu'avant et avec jean jacques
goldman et la femme de coluche qui il y
a un peu calmé les jeux mais des
guéguerres de deggo dans les [ __ ] ça
fait des années j'entends elle vous êtes
la seule avec guillaume à penser qu'ils
en forêt sont pas en danger là autour de
la table et c'est comme une cause
humanitaire on ne sait pas de problème
ça là on est tous d'accord sur la cause
ne prenne justement comme si une belle
cause six en danger il ya un problème et
pourquoi peut-être ne pas tout
simplement en parler essayer de régler
plutôt que de vue danser verriez vous
n'en savez rien tout ça c'est de légumes
vous n'en savez rien il ya d'abord il ya
45 égaux donc personne n'en sait rien ça
fait par dont les choux gras de de nos
amis que j'adore de la presse people en
fait on dit rosanna parce qu'on nous a
dit de dire tout le temps quand on est
petit à petit et je vous adore parce que
c'est vrai que vous vous aimez beaucoup
il ya direz vous mais en plus on s'est
vraiment bien mais oui moi je pense que
tout ça tout c'est beaucoup de bruit
pour rien du tout il ya quand même anne
marcassus il ya quand même une cause qui
les quittent les dépasser ses séries
phares et qu'il vient de dire tout s'est
décidé d'écouler non mais si tout le
monde en parle comme ça est ce que vous
voulez suivre vous pensez sébastien qui
sont en danger pourquoi parce que vous
avez les infos vous les suivez vous
entendez des choses non j'ai pas des
infos particulière et tout a été plus ou
moins 10 mais c'est vrai que depuis qui
appuie jean jacques goldman et véronique
colucci et les guerres d'ego vont
sûrement faire du mal et il ya peut-être
aussi l'usure ya peut-être pas assez de
renouvellement au niveau des artistes
tout ça fait que évidemment avec le
temps je pense que ça va baisser un
petit peu en tout cas ça baisse déjà on
le voit on le voit saab est évidemment
sur les audiences la boîte à musique en
2013 donc leur show c'était c'était 12
millions de personnes et le dernier show
des [ __ ] en 2018 donc les visas puis
goldman c29 pignon c'est un tiers km2
chute oui ça c'est dramatique
rappelons quand même que les [ __ ] ça
sert juste à alimenter les ruines du
coeur qui servent chaque année environ
130 2 millions de repas et c'est aussi
ils vivent aussi des dons des français
donc si ces guéguerres sont vraies et
justes
c'est faux que ça va s'arranger en effet
mais si les jeunes artistes ne vient pas
c'est très embêtant pour la vente pour
qu'il joue ma question est ce que tu as
que les gens regardent moins le show
parce que justement les assortiments qui
est des guerres d'ego et qui sont moins
touchés par la cause est ce que c'est
parce que les gens moins d'argent je ne
sais pas mais en tout cas visiblement ça
a un impact qui se dit donc est-ce que
l'impact est ce que c'est vous presse
people vous êtes responsable de ça vous
vous créez un malaise là dedans et du
coup les gens regardent moins et achète
moi ou est-ce qu'au contraire vous
dénoncez vraiment non une guerre d'égos
et ce qui est le contraire parce que les
[ __ ] c'était vraiment une grande
messe que tout le monde adoré ça marche
encore bien parce que 9 millions c'est
encore énorme mais sa baisse mais c'est
si on en parlait justement de dire
ségara a piqué la maquilleuse de trucs
et au contraire ça faisait partie un peu
du show de dire mais comment ils se
regardent comment il parle ça sacré
quand même de l'événement quelque part
le problème sacrément l événement parce
qu'à moins de gens qui vont parce qu'il
ya moins d'artistes qui m'ont parce
qu'avant il fallait y aller il fallait
s'y précipiter a été un honneur d'être
conviés aux [ __ ] et alors les gens
qui n'étaient pas conviés c'est horrible
j'ai envie d'être aimé mais ce qui est
vrai guillaume parce que vous disiez
tout à l'heure des 45 ego bas à l'époque
de goldman qu'avec m 45 personnes qui
évidemment veulent la meilleure chanson
malgré tout s'arrêtait artistes
eigenmann français à la partie
d'allemagne fait l'ouverture tu seras
deuxième rang d'icône varoise étrangères
le patron mais elle avait un patron il
ya quand même une bonne nouvelle goldman
va revenir pour les 30 ans des [ __ ]
ça c'est une mégane va être absolument
ça montre que je de son moyen voilà
c'est pas en danger a confirmé mais ça
donne forcément je pense qu'il faut
qu'il revienne voila voila je viens
faire là tu as appelé ben je suis
d'accord avec jennifer pour une fois
vous a posé la question à vous oui dans
la cabine question qu'on se pose même si
tout ce groupe là enfin des restes en
arrive à sauter tous ensemble le ravin
c'est à la pro prochain événement est ce
que les gens ne remettront pas en cause
la sincérité tout ça en fait mais
peut-être c'est pour ça que je me
demande si la presse people a une
responsabilité ou pas où aller nous qui
selon vous a posé la question les
[ __ ] sont ils en danger
voilà non mais mais quand même je pense
que de mal à s'arrêter 80 20 voilà